we're less than a year away from the
2016 presidential election which means
we'll be hearing a lot more about
immigration especially considering the
Supreme Court is deciding on the fate of
President Obama's executive actions his
initiatives would defer the deportations
of an estimated 5 million undocumented
immigrants and give them permits to work
legally in the US these policies don't
permanently block deportations or offer
a path to citizenship and not all
undocumented people qualify for the
programs but for many it's the only
protection they have which means that
there's a much bigger problem at hand
our immigration system is broken here
are three reasons why we need to fix it
there are nearly 11 million undocumented
people currently living in the US and
almost 17 million people live in mixed
status families that means at least one
family member is undocumented life can
mean fear of being discovered and
deported that fear sometimes stops them
from taking their kids to school
reporting crimes to the police or even
going to the doctor over 90% of those
detained and deported are men creating
many single-mother household struggling
to provide for their children who remain
in the country and deportations haven't
helped us improve our immigration system
they've cost us over five billion
dollars per year it isn't cheap
we're talking about ten thousand dollars
per person deported when you combine the
costs of detaining these individuals
processing them through courts and
transporting them abroad money that
could surely benefit say America's
schools or infrastructure and while
certain presidential hopefuls wanted to
port all undocumented immigrants the
vast majority of Americans have said
otherwise numerous polls over the years
have found that most Americans believe
undocumented immigrants should be
allowed to remain in the country if they
meet certain legal requirements and most
undocumented people have lived in the US
for over a decade and are pretty
integrated into society of course
finally fixing our immigration system
would be a huge boost to the economy
putting undocumented immigrants on a
path to citizenship and figuring out
legal limits to future immigration would
add more than 1.5 trillion dollars to
the GDP over the next decade legalized
immigrants are more protected and may
more money which means more tax revenue
in fact if undocumented people had legal
status local and state tax revenue would
increase by an estimated 2.2 billion
dollars a year and that means more
people would spend more money which
means more jobs for Americans having
comprehensive immigration reform is
becoming more of a necessity than ever
before so wonderful politicians catch up
and step up